[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es einen stark
angefragt das rezept endlich endlich ihr
habt alle jahre gesagt geh wann machst
du endlich und heute ist es soweit heute
machen wir es selber gefüllte
weinblätter auf arabisch genau und es
gibt noch ganz viele andere begriffe
dafür aus anderen ländern treibt es mit
gelber in die kommentare
was es auch gibt sind viele verschiedene
arten einmal zuzubereiten heute meist um
sind typisch türkisch wobei auch in der
türkei unterscheiden sich die
zubereitungs weisen ihr könnt mir gern
auch mal in die kommentare schreiben was
ihr haben was macht und wie ihr das
zubereitet wenn ich denk mal im
arabischen raum werden sie auch noch mal
anders gemacht
ja es gibt auch eine libanesische
variante der ist dann auch noch mal
richtig viel olivenöl manche türken
machen das dann auch ganz komplett ohne
zu wissen mit ganz wenig die starken
akku sehr genau
also man kann das thema breit schlagen
ganz viel darüber reden das können wir
gerne in den kommentaren machen ich
zeige euch jetzt alle erstmal die
zutaten
wir benötigen rundkornreis außerdem
weinblätter hier habe ich petersilie und
zwiebeln an gewürzen salz pfeffer
getrocknete minze und paprika flocken
hier habe ich olivenöl paprika mark und
tomatenmark außerdem granatapfel zero
eine zitrone und kartoffeln sowie
beginnt jetzt mit der füllung und die
besteht ja aus reis und zum paar gewürze
tomaten und paprika mag alles was wir
gerade gesehen habt bis auf zitrone
kartoffeln und weinblätter gehen jetzt
alles zum reich und verkneten das
ordentlich mit den händen
[Musik]
und in meine füllung kommt immer
granatapfel leute es schmeckt so gut das
schmeckt ja so ein bisschen süß
säuerlich gibt da ruhig ein und halb
esslöffel ungefähr rein und das beste
das gibt es in meinem shop jetzt alles
ordentlich durch reden hier 35
so jetzt habe ich alles gut
durchgeknetet das ganze dauert ja nur
eine minute und jetzt ist die füllung
fertig und wir widmen uns den
weinblättern das motto willst ja
sozusagen das dauert lange weil das
jetzt befüllen werden und sagt ja auch
dafür das haben wir wirklich schon
fleißig hilft ja so ganz fertig sind wir
noch nicht
ich zeig euch jetzt mal die weinblätter
entweder habt ihr das glück und ihr
könnt frischen pflücken viele werden
viele machen müsste auch so die fluten
das und frieren dass dann ein und dann
kann man sie kochen und abschrecken und
dann sind sie eben bereit das glück
hatte ich jetzt leider nicht ich hatte
keine frischen da habe jetzt die
konservierten genommen aus dem glas
wichtig ist leute ihr müsst die richtig
schön ausspülen denn da ist ja salz drin
in dem wasser und sonst schmeckt das am
ende viel zeit ich habe jetzt zweimal
ausgespült und dann hab ich auch den
stil entfernt und hier zu befüllen wir
das ganze so jetzt habe ich hier schon
ein bisschen was vorbereitet und ich
zeige euch mal meine einrollt technik
wichtig ist das wie gesagt die stille ab
sind die brauchen wir hier nicht
und dass ihr die grobe seite nach oben
macht also die glatte seite kommt nach
unten
und jetzt nehmen wir uns immer ca 1
teelöffel von unserer reis füllung geben
dass hier unten
das war nicht ganz geben dass hier unten
einmal drauf und jetzt fangen wir an
einfach hier einzurollen und wichtig ist
dass es ganz eng eingeräumt wird
[Musik]
und sobald wir dann in der mitte
angekommen sind nehmen wir die
seitenklappe die einmal ein und dann
weiterhin sehr eng bis zum ende hin
aufrollen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet
natürlich haben sie mir nicht geholfen
habt euch gewundert was natürlich das
machen wir wieder um linie nein das ist
auch gut für lokale sind doch wo und ob
aufgehen hit ist es nämlich wichtig dass
wir das alles vernünftig im topf
geschichten
es kann sein dass es euch unten anbrennt
bisschen hat man immer diesen trick so
ein paar weinblätter die zerbrochen oder
hässlich sind oder die man nicht
gebrauchen kann er wird wie ich das
meine dass man die einfach auf den
topfboden gibt und danach nehmen die
kartoffelscheiben ganz einfach weil die
weinblätter ja relativ salzig sind wir
haben es zwar schon ausgespielt aber zur
sicherheit gibt man auf den topf wohnen
jetzt noch mal dicke kartoffelscheiben
die fangen nämlich das salz auf wir
müssen in einem diesen draw also die
müsst ihr nicht vorkommen dass wir ja
quatsch aber das schützt einfach noch
mal zusätzlich
[Musik]
es ist die erste lage ist aber im topf
und wichtig ist dass ihr das schön eng
aneinander an wright das heißt nicht so
viel platz lassen damit sich auch nicht
aufgeben und ich mache jetzt die zweite
schicht und gibst du dein ganz einfach
oben drüber
[Musik]
auch die sommers kommen jetzt
zitronenscheiben die sind unverzichtbar
und dadurch wird es nun so richtig
lecker dem ich jetzt ganz einfach oben
drauf und jetzt nehmt ihr euch irgend
einen teller der in den topf passt und
gebt ihm umgedreht obendrauf das
beschwert das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen und bewegt dass es eben nicht
aufgehen kann
wenn jetzt alle schritte beachtet haben
dann haben hinterher perfekt ist warum
hast jetzt brauchen in kochendes wasser
also das sollte schon aufgekocht sein
und geben das oben drüber so das wasser
gerade so dass dies etwas bedeckt sind
und nicht mehr die dürfen nicht der topf
nicht überschwemmt seien von wasser
jetzt gebe ich oben drüber noch ein
kleines bisschen olivenöl das ist auch
geschmackssache
so also hat meine mutter gezeigt so am
rand so ein bisschen ist natürlich noch
mal geschmackssache
generell gilt übrigens ist soll ja leute
geben die kein olivenöl mögen aber wirst
du ja übrigens auch so echt als
jugendliche mochte ich kein olivenöl und
mittlerweile liebe ich das und wenn ihr
das nicht mehr könnt ihr das im rezept
komplett durchgesetzt
so jetzt catherine kiki kein deckel für
ausgerechnet diesen topf den ich für
star benötige deshalb gebe ich dann
gleich nochmal ein ganz normaler
obendrauf hauptsache es ist luftdicht
verschlossen und dann gehen wir rüber
zum herd so das wasser kocht und es muss
auch jetzt gar nicht lange kochen wir
gehen jetzt runter mit dem herd auf die
mittlere stufe ich wird sogar fast sagen
etwas niedriger als mittlere stufe
und jetzt muss das so circa eine stunde
vor sich hin garen ihr könnt natürlich
auch zwischendurch mal ein öffnen
schauen auswechslung durch ist es kommt
natürlich auch immer auch die menge an
die ihr zubereitet ganz kurzer hinweis
falls ihr noch füllung übrig habt dann
macht euch einfach paprika und befüllt
die mit der füllung und dann könnte es
eigentlich im prinzip entweder mit garen
lassen im topf oder in meinem fall so
habe ich nämlich für morgen schon mal
essen vorbereitet könnt ihr das auch im
ofen
dann mit der tomatensauce habe ich mir
schon gedacht haben sie wird immer die
rote ich bin auch mit der grün zufrieden
dann sehen wir uns gleich und weil er
damals dann ist macht es keinen sinn
jetzt zu warten bis sie fertig sind denn
ich kann ja eh nicht vor der kamera
probieren aber ich versichere euch sind
sehr sehr würzig und lecker und nach der
anleitung darf euch eigentlich auch
nichts schief gehen
also ich warte jetzt noch die ganze zeit
ab dann seht ihr wie ich das ganze
servieren dazu passt am besten zitronen
joghurt und zitrone auch dann hab ich
gar nicht mal so unrecht
da haben sie erwartet manchmal nicht in
frage und dann sind es ist sowieso schon
testen so der schule ja auch immer passt
dazu sehr gut joghurt und gern auch
zitrone und salat und ich mag es auch
gern als hauptspeise haben sagt das ist
doch beilage das ist kein ort naja
werden wir noch essen von gestern und
das ist mir dazu und wenn wir auf
instagram heute sieht auch immer wie wir
da machen willst du so aussieht bei uns
genau ansonsten folgt mir gerne dort und
hier sowieso wenn es nicht schon längst
tut was wollte ich auch sagen wir müssen
aus dem konzept
aber sonst war ich mal was ist fertig
und dann erst naja ich wünsche euch ist
ganz viel spaß ihm nachmachen
ich habe auch einmal genau schauen denn
die infobox zu die genauen mengenangaben
und dann sehen wir uns auch im nächsten
mal auf den tisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]